بعد نصف قرن على اخر رحله امريكيه الى
القمر من هذا النوع ناسا اطلقت الصاروخ
الاقوى في العالم مدشنه عصرا جديدا هذه
المره يضمن نقل طواقم بشريه الى القمر في
السنوات المقبله واقامه وجود بشري دائم
على القمر وبناء محطه فضائيه في مداره
واطلقت وكاله الفضاء الامريكيه ناسا مهمات
ارتمسوان غير الماهوله الى القمر في اعقاب
العديد من التاخيرات بسبب مشكلات فنيه
وسوء الاحوال الجويه هذا واطلق ارتم
النسوان الذي يصل ارتفاعه الى 100 متر الى
السماء ليتسبب في مزيج مذهل من الصوت
والضوء حيث سيكون الهدف الرئيسي من هذه
الحمله الاستكشافيه التي ستستمر ل 25 يوما
نقل طواقم مستقبليه الى القمر ويشكل هذا
الحدث الانطلاق الكبيره لبرنامج ارتميس
حيث سيتم الاقتراب من القمر عندما سوف تصل
الى اربعه و60000 كم
رقم القياسيه لمركبه قابله للسكن ضمن رحله
هي الاولى من نوعها ضمن برنامج ارتميس
الامريكي
[موسيقى]